[Musique]
bonjour donc va ça a été dit je plaide
fatmata kébé et je voulais commencer
cette présentation en partageant avec
vous une image que j'aime beaucoup
donc qui est derrière moi donc vous
voyez un morceau de la planète saturne
qui se définit enfin qui est
reconnaissable à ses anneaux et il ya un
petit point lumineux sur la droite de
l'image et ce petit point en fait c'est
nous c'est la planète terre est vrai
qu'avec la vie de tous les jours on a
tendance à oublier ce qui nous entoure
et sur tout ce qui est dans le ciel est
avec cette photo en fait ça me fait
voyager et ça va bientôt faire 20 ans
fait que je regarde toutes ces images et
que je m'imagine dans une combinaison
par exemple d'astronautes et je suis en
train de regarder cette superbe
nébuleuse des fois je lui ai dit je vais
aller un peu je me rapproche un peu de
la terre
à droite vers le balafon d'accord merci
pour la logique ivoirienne voilà par
exemple je suis sur la lune et je
regarde un superbe levée de terre et des
fois je reste sur terre et je regarde
notre magnifique galaxie la voie lactée
et du coup vers l'âge de 8 10 ans je me
suis dis pas plus tard je travaillerai
dans les étoiles
voilà je serai une astronaute
spationautes cosmonaute tout ce que vous
voulez et donc je le retrouve
aujourd'hui à finir une thèse
d'astronomie dans un institut de
l'observatoire de paris et je travaille
sur ça donc la boule que vous voyez en
fait c'est vraiment la terre et les
petits pan autour c'est sujet de mon
étude c'est des points dont la taille a
été grossi parce que dans l'espace et
est très grand et ses petits points ce
sont des déchets qui ont délaissé par
l'être humain dans le cadre de
l'exploitation spatiale et le terme
technique pour définir ces objets c'est
débris spatiaux et par exemple avec
cette image on arrive bien apercevoir la
distribution de ces objets autour de la
terre et par exemple on estime qu'il y à
peu près 100 millions de débris donc de
déchets qui ont une taille inférieure à
1 cm et qui tourne autour de notre
planète
donc aujourd'hui on peut pas vraiment
dire que je travaille dans les étoiles
on va pas non plus dire que je travaille
dans les déchets c'est une phase de
transition
voilà parce que au mali nous sommes des
personnes consciencieuses et voilà donc
en fait moi quand je suis dans mon
laboratoire
je me dis juste que voilà je suis une
personne j'ai trouvé ma vocation
et je fais tout pour rendre concrète
cette vocation que je me suis trouvé ça
pourrait être simple mais après le
contexte dans lequel je vis fait que
assez compliquée dès fois de rester
stable sur son chemin donc comme ça a
été dit je suis d'origine malienne et
tout à l'heure j'ai entendu une
présentation on disait que les africains
avaient perdu confiance en eux en regard
de certaines tragédies de l'histoire
mais que si on connaissait notre
histoire on saurait qu'il ya eu de
grands royaumes de grands empires donc à
partir de maintenant je vais dire que je
viens de l' empire du mali voilà en
france j'ai eu l'occasion de découvrir
un grand écrivain de vampires du mali
qui s'appelle amadou hampate ba j'ai
vraiment aimé tous les livres que j'ai
pu trouver de lui en france et la
première fois que je perds tout le mali
je devais avoir dans la vingtaine
j'étais super contente
pardon j'ai dit malice et empire du mali
j'étais super contente parce que je me
suis dit voilà je suis sur la terre-mère
d'amadou hampaté bah j'ai tout découvrir
tous ses écrits
tous ces travaux et cetera et cetera est
en fête
lol en fait en france il est plus facile
de trouver des travaux d'amadou hampâté
bâ qu'au mali dans le pire du mali voilà
des gens est entretenu et ça c'est très
bien si les présidents ib câble regarde
voilà
et donc j'ai aussi bah tant pis on va
faire avec
et l'année dernière j'ai surtout rno
valley dans le cadre d enfin d'un projet
que je mène là bas je travaille sur un
système d'irrigation dans l'agriculture
parce qu'en fait il faut savoir qu'à la
base je travaille dans la mécanique des
fluides et je suis ingénieur et comme
j'aime bien les problèmes dès qu'ils ont
un problème j'aime bien essayer de
travailler dessus et donc mal et soudain
rendu compte que l'agriculture consommer
beaucoup d'eau que les gens avaient
perdu
cette connaissance d'irriguer en
quantité optimale leurs plantes et du
coup actuellement fabrique des capteurs
en fait qui permet d'économiser cette
eau est donc l'année dernière pendant
que je faisais une phase pilote de ces
capteurs j'ai eu l'occasion d'organiser
des activités autour des technologies de
l'information et de la communication
dtic avec des filles de petite fille de
mon quartier à bamako vous avez des
ordinateurs des appareils photo et des
tablettes et géo filles pour certaines
vous allez écrire des histoires sur
l'ordinateur
d'autres vous allez nous filmer et
d'autres facteurs lieu d'autres filles
donc les filles avaient à peu près entre
8,9 et au final ça a été ma porte quoi
même c'est pas grave parce qu'en fait ce
qui était magnifique avec ses petites
filles c'est que c'était la première
fois qu'elle touchera ce type de
technologie et c'était pour me rendre
compte aussi que mes parents beaucoup de
membres de ma famille ont quitté le mali
pour vous offrir une vie meilleure
entre guillemets mais aussi pour nourrir
quand vous devez tout à l'heure dix
personnes en moyenne
je dis ça parce qu'en fait beaucoup de
personnes me félicite sur mon parcours
mais sincèrement quand vous êtes en
france et que vous regardez les mamans
africaines qui se lève à 4h 5h du matin
pour faire le ménage
elles finissent à 8 heures avant que les
gens intègrent leurs bureaux et
repartent le soir travailler à 19 heures
quand les gens à quitter leurs bureaux
pour revenir chez elle à 23h et moi je
pense que vraiment c'est elle qui devra
être sur scène dans ce tte dicks parce
que ce cet exemple d'humilité
[Applaudissements]
cet exemple d'humilité et même si elle
gagne pas des mille et des cents je
trouve qu'en afrique c'est le meilleur
modèle de réussite qui existe et c'est
vraiment pour ça que je me dis des fois
comment je peux oser me plaindre quand
je vois que tous les sacrifices qu'on
peut faire toutes ces femmes et je vous
dis soit aussi parce qu'en fait au mali
je serai avec une coopérative de femmes
qu'ils ont formée a utilisé également
des technologies de l'information et de
la communication et tout les matins
elles sont là à 5 heures du matin pour
broyer le mille pour partir en classe
pour aller nourrir leur famille pour
revenir en cours et pour encore
travailler et travailler je vous parle
de ça parce qu'en fait l'empiré du mali
c'est un contexte assez particulier
était particulier du fait de son
histoire
et parce qu'en fait que ma faim l'
empire du mali fait partie de moi c'est
mes racines
donc je vous décris comme franco
malienne parce que quoi qu'il arrive
j'ai une partie française en moi que je
ne peux pas renier et non plus 7 ce côté
en fait de vampires du mali mais là je
vais partir en france ou en septembre
dernier du conseil national de
l'évaluation du système scolaire a
rempli des rapports sur l'égalité des
chances dans le système éducatif
français est en fait malgré son niveau
économique est assez élevé la france a
malheureusement un système d'éducation
qui est très inégalitaire
par exemple vous prenez un élève qui
veut d'un établissement réputé en fin de
collège il aura acquis 80% des
compétences demandées en français vous
prenez un étudiant qui vient d'une école
plus ou moins en moyenne pour le même
niveau d'études
il aura acquis que 35% des compétences
demandées en français et forcément avec
le temps ces écarts pour se creuser
il y à peu près cinq ans j'ai une amie
qui donnait des cours de soutien des
devoirs à bobigny qui est une ville de
banlieue française
il y avait une fille qui avais
12 13 ans qui lui a dit façon madame ça
ne sert à rien que je continue à
travailler à l'école parce que je suis
nul je me suis fait que pour travailler
au kfc
on n'a rien contre kfc miser sur la
symbolique de se dire qu'à 12 13 ans
elle est capable de dire que sa vie est
déjà finie et qu'en fait il n'y a que ça
qui existe comme proposition pour elle
moi de mon côté je faisais je parcourais
des collèges et lycées pour faire la
promotion de la science inciter les
jeunes à l'aise avec carrières
scientifiques et surtout les filles est
en fait pareil ce qui me gênait un peu
c'était tout le temps donc vous
fatoumata kébé on a bien dit fatoumata
le prénom bien caricatural par
définition vous vous faites de
l'astronomie
le pire c'est quand des personnes de
l'impur du mali viennent me voir on
mitraille des parents et ont laissé
faire
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas que mes parents ont laissé
faire c'est que mes parents m'ont fait
confiance
parce que pour eux ce qui compte c'est
que je puisse vivre correctement avec ma
vie donc pour donner le change au début
ma mère quand j'ai eu le bac elle m'a
dit ma fille je suis fier de toi
vraiment il avait les larmes aux yeux et
elle m'a dit maintenant tu vas y
postuler chez carrefour pour devenir
caissière
mais je sais que quand elle me disait ça
c'est parce qu'elle se disait que je
gagne assez d'argent pour rire
correctement même si je pense que ma
part un peu respectée quand on m'a dit
ça mais bref donc les dames à merveille
tant qu'aide s'inquiète pas inquiète
donc j'ai car vous travailler à temps
partiel et j'ai poursuivi mes études
normales licence master jusqu'au jour où
je lui ai dit oui maman moi j'aimerais
bien travailler dans le l'aérospatiale
faire ingénieurs l'ont dit oui pourquoi
pas si tu veux donc du coup bah j'ai
l'opportunité de partir au japon déjà
pensé ou sa petite soeur qui vient qui
dit basse et les mandats
ok et quoi qu'il en soit mes parents ont
laissé partir au japon pendant un an
pour être formés à l'aérospatiale ma
mère m'a dit et mes parents mon père
aussi penser que havas calme et c'est
bon elle a fait son master va travailler
elle va ramener de l'argent et cetera et
cetera
je vous ai pas dit c'est quoi une thèse
je dis ça mais par an c'est quoi le test
quand j'ai expressément dit non non tu
as fait de la sorcellerie
non je plaisante non mais ça va puisque
en fait en tant que d art en tant que dr
hop je suis considéré comme étant une
jeune chercheur donc j'ai comme un
salaire donc ça va mais tout ça pour
vous dire en fait que à force de parler
avec les jeunes le problème c'est que il
avait intégré le fait que ce n'était pas
normal qu'une fille comme moi face de
l'astronomie et que du coup j'étais pas
un profil à reproduire
et quand je leur demandais toi tu veux
faire quoi plus tard moi franchement du
mois que je trouve un travail peuvent
être tranquilles et tout c'est bon ça
suffit
j'ai pas être médecin ou des choses
comme ça franchement c'est vrai qu'à la
base je voulais que mes deux seins mais
vous savez c'est pas ben c'est pas
forcément pour nous on peut c'est
difficile on peut ceci en plus cela donc
il me demander des fois mais est ce
qu'il ya des personnes enfin d'autres
fatoumata à l'observatoire de paris
et parce qu'un feuilleton se rend pas
compte de l'importance d'avoir des
modèles qui nous ressemblent dans divers
domaines bien que ma réponse était
négative effectivement je suis seul
fatoumata mais ça n'empêche mbit/s
castro nomi c'est pour une élite
quand même les gens qui ont un certain
niveau intellectuel etc etc
et du coup je me suis dit deux ans plus
tard j'ai créé l'association éphémérides
qui s'est donné pour but d'enseigner
l'astronomie à tout le monde mais
surtout envers des jeunes qui viennent
de quartiers dits difficiles je t'ai dit
que bas peut-être qu'en ayant des
notions d'astronomie il est peut-être
changé leur perception sur ce domaine et
surtout que sade et briser certaines
chaînes qui s'était mis autour d'eux et
donc pendant des mois nous les efforts
mais avec les un télescope
le monte tout seul vers le ciel
reconnaître les étoiles et mine de rien
bon après c'est parce qu'ils sont jeunes
ils se la pètent à un peu madame ce soir
on va regarder la constellation du cygne
est tous dans des jeux pour ajouter des
scop robin mais j'étais contente parce
qu'en fait du coup en fait il suffisait
juste de leur apporter ça en fait parce
que deux mêmes n'auraient jamais pensé à
les solliciter une association de
transit pour dire voilà j'aimerais
apprendre donc au final bas ça marche
assez bien et j'aimerais d'ailleurs
remercié la fondation de france qui m'a
remis une bourse l'année dernière et qui
m'a permis d'acheter deux télescopes
supplémentaire pour faire encore plus
atelier d'astronomie
[Applaudissements]
il ya un proverbe qui dit tous les
chemins mènent à rome
c'est un professeur qui nous l'avait dit
au collège et j'ai trop crédules des
fois et du coup quand il m'a dit ça je
suis bien fait c'est bon et tout si je
travaille si je fais si je fais ça j'y
arrive et là je rajoute le deuxième lol
en fait oui on peut y arriver
mais quand on dit tous les chemins
mènent à rome j'ai réfléchi parce que
j'ai une scientifique il faut poser la
phrase a décortiqué essaie de la
comprendre
oui il ya plusieurs chemins qui existent
pour arriver au même endroit mais ce
chemin il va dépendre de la douve n'est
en fait de qui vous êtes et il va
dépendre de plusieurs facteurs est ce
que vous connaissez votre histoire est
ce que vous savez pourquoi vous avez
choisi quel chemin parce que sur des
chemins vous aurez des impasses il
voudrait faire demi-tour recommencer
pour prendre un autre chemin jemaye sera
escarpée peut-être ou alors le chemin il
se rappela ce sera facile pour vous et
tant mieux
éphéméride en astronomie
c'est un ouvrage qui contient les
positions des astres un intervalle de
temps régulier c'est à dire qu'avec cet
ouvrage tous les mois je sais où se
situe jupiter dans le ciel et il choisi
ce mot pour la définition mais aussi
parce que c'est le nom de mon institut
qui s'appelle l'institut de mécanique
céleste et de calcul des éphémérides et
je t'ai dit que va peut-être qu'il
existe des éphémérides humaine en gros
un instant donné
donc les à chacun d'entre vous de votre
position mais là vous êtes particulier
c'est qu'en fait on pourra jamais
calculé intervalles de temps réguliers
où vous serez pas ce que vous serez
dépendra uniquement est avant tout de
vous les décisions que vous allez
prendre
et je voulais cité une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup mais tout à l'heure il ya une
vidéo qui me la piquer la phrase ne
m'appartient pas mais bon je pense avoir
l'exclusivité peut-être exceptions sait
jamais c'est de confucius un philosophe
chinois qui disait trouve un travail que
tu n es tu n'auras pas travailler un
seul jour de ta vie
aujourd'hui surtout pour la jeune
génération il y a des facilités qui
n'existait pas on va dire à notre époque
et si vous pouvez les saisir surtout les
filles j'ai su pour l'égalité hommes
femmes
bien évidemment mais surtout pour les
filles et non non mais tout ça pour dire
que l'égalité hommes-femmes c'est une
question qui est un peu compliquée qui
concerne le monde entier et je veux pas
continuer de suivre parce que je me fais
expulser de côte d'ivoire
non tout ça pour dire que je vous
souhaite d'arriver là où boulot là vous
voulez être et surtout être les acteurs
de changement de l'appliquer parce qu'il
ya plein d'études qui disent l'afrique
en 2050 premier continent dans six dans
sa dissidence à ma seule question c'est
à qui ça va profiter ce qui va être les
propriétaires des plus grandes
entreprises qu'on trouvera en afrique
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un dans la salle
si oui n'oubliez pas
[Applaudissements]
et j'aimerais finir par remercier
encourager des gens de tedx à abidjan
parce que c'est pas facile j'ai fait
technics à paris champs elysées
on se bat pas ce qu'il écrit
champs-elysées que ça veut dire c'est un
teddy que c'est une version particulière
qui était superbe et c'était pour les
encourager parce que je redis que mine
de rien de s'engager dans cette voie
d'essayer d'organiser un tel événement
en afrique
franchement respect voilà merci